this building during the series the
impressive game one victory
and then of course that great comeback
in game five greg williams
tatum backs up looking to get a head
start here shot clock at six
kicks it out to williams williams on the
drive goes inside lays it up and in
allen
kicks it out to porters up top the
holiday holiday gets in the paint back
up top matthews blocked by williams
brant williams the rejection
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
grant williams again left open
knocks it down and the individual
defense and then the help defense
for both these teams
final minute first half grant williams
connects on a three
[Music]
percupos attempted three three-pointers
he's one for three grant williams hits
another three matthews forcing ground
left nearly comes up with a steal
finds smart kicks it out in the corner
grant williams another three
bucks have proven time and again they're
never out of it
horford fakes horford drives inside
williams for the flush
what a beautiful setup from al horford
ahead to brown brown's got nine points
in the period 19 for the game
white williams three-pointer
giannis on the drive splits the defense
too strong on the layup horford the
rebound he's missed three point-blank
layups tonight that you just don't see
him miss grant williams again
tatum wide open
portis running the other way
bobby portis goes up trying to throw it